[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es klingt absurd und ist doch warm
Donald Trump könnte nächstes Jahr
vielleicht ins Gefängnis gehen oder
vielleicht wieder US-Präsident werden
beides ist seit heute theoretisch
möglich noch nie zuvor in der Geschichte
musste sich ein früherer US-Präsident in
einem Strafverfahren Stellen Donald
Trump ist seit heute der erste in New
York wurden soeben die 34 das wissen wir
nun Anklagepunkte gegen ihn verlesen
worum es in der Anklage geht vor allem
geht die schweigegeldzahlungen gezahlt
von Trump an Pornodarstellerin stormy
Daniels und wir hatten letzte Woche auch
schon darüber berichtet hier bei uns in
der Sendung und heute wird das Ganze
eben konkreter ich fasse noch mal kurz
zusammen die Zahlung an sich die sind
nicht das Problem sondern dass Trump sie
als Anwaltskosten deklariert haben soll
und er könnte damit außerdem gegen
Gesetze zur Wahlkampf Finanzierung
verstoßen haben und heute musste er nach
New York kommen und sich eben diese 34
35 Anklagepunkte anhören und hat dann
laut mehreren uS-Medien berichten auf
nicht schuldig plädiert und welche
Anklagepunkte das konkret sind die gegen
ihn erhoben wurden das ist heute live
bei uns in der Sendung für euch Thema
denn es gibt eine Pressekonferenz gleich
von der Oberstaatsanwaltschaft die wir
live mitnehmen und das Ganze für euch
natürlich danach auch analysieren wie
geht es jetzt weiter was bedeutet das
bedeutet das Game Over für Trump oder
was bedeutet das auch für seine Pläne
erneut US-Präsident zu werden ihr könnt
Fragen dazu stellen natürlich jederzeit
bei uns im Stream oder auch per Mail mit
kommentieren und wir sprechen zu
allererst mit unserem Korrespondenten
live in New York Johannes Hano er ist
nämlich schon den ganzen Tag dort vor
Ort und Johannes du bist eben vor Ort
für uns und Trump hat das Gericht
bereits verlassen wir haben Bilder davon
gesehen hat er sich denn jetzt schon
irgendwie geäußert zu diesen 34 an
klargepunkten
nein da haben wir noch nichts gehört das
ist noch nichts bekannt dass er sich
geäußert ist hieß im Vorfeld dass er
möglicherweise an einer Kamera
vorbeilaufen wird die im Gericht
aufgestellt war also nicht im
Gerichtsraum selber sondern in einem
Foyer es war angekündigt dass er
möglicherweise dort eine Stellungnahme
abgibt aber soweit wir wissen hat er das
nicht getan es hat sowieso alles sehr
sehr lange gedauert und ein Grund dafür
dass das so lange gedauert hat war der
die sagt die Tatsache dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft eine ganz andere
Sache noch auf Tapete gehoben hat man
hat nämlich gesagt Donald Trump hat in
den vergangenen Wochen die
Staatsanwaltschaft aber auch das Gericht
massiv angegriffen und bedroht und das
sah einige Farben möglicherweise für die
Juroren und man wollte hier erreichen
und das hat man wahrscheinlich auch
erreicht das Trump in Zukunft nicht
öffentlich über die Geschworenen jetzt
noch rausgesucht werden müssen sprechen
darf aus Angst dass denen etwas zustößt
insgesamt sind es du hast gesagt 34 an
Tage Punkte wohl im Detail kennen wir
die nicht die Anklageschrift wird
demnächst erst veröffentlicht aber
einige Reporter die in dem Gerichtszeit
drin waren haben gesagt es sind 34
Straftaten mit das Ziel eine
Verschwörung zu vertuschen Verschwörung
in dem Sinne dass da mehrere Menschen
involviert waren die diese
schweigegeldzahlungen an stormy Daniels
und möglicherweise das wissen wir noch
nicht genau auch an eine Playboy eine
Playboy Model gezahlt haben um den
Wahlkampf zu beeinflussen um negative
News von Trump abzuhalten auf den
letzten Metern des Wahlkampfes und das
wäre dann eine illegale
Wahlkampffinanzierung und eins muss man
sich klar machen
Donald Trumps ehemalige Anwalt Michael
Cohen der wurde für genau diese Sache
schon von einem Bundesgericht zum
mehreren Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt
damals hieß es in dem Urteil dass
Michael Kohn das im Auftrag von
Individuum eins getan hat Individuum
eins das war Donald Trump man konnte
damals nicht gegen ihn ermitteln weil er
Präsident war und das scheint sich jetzt
zu ändern
hat gesagt
es ist jetzt Zeit der Gerechtigkeit
gekommen denn es können ja nicht sein
dass der Handlanger ins Gefängnis muss
und der Auftraggeber ungeschoren davon
kommt das ist ein Medienspektakel die
US-Sender zeigen wirklich jeden Schritt
und Tritt von Trump auf dem Weg danach
nach New York zur Verlegung der
Anklageschrift wird 24 Stunden live da
gerade berichtet wie kommt das an bei
den Amerikanerinnen und Amerikanern ist
das Interesse wirklich so groß nach wie
vor an der Person Donald Trump wie wird
das eingeschätzt dass da gerade so
massiv wieder über ihn über natürlich
auch Ihnen den Medien Mensch berichtet
wird
also das liegt nicht nur an Donald Trump
sondern es liegt auch an der Tatsache
dass es tatsächlich ein historisches
Verfahren ist das ist das erste Mal in
der US-Geschichte dass ein Ex-Präsident
angeklagt wird das hat es noch nie
gegeben und insofern die Medien sind ja
teilweise selbstkritisch die sagen ja
wir heben Donald Trump jetzt wieder ganz
nach oben auf das Schild und alle
berichten drüber aber wir müssen das tun
denn es ist ein historisches first in
amerikanischen Geschichte und
tatsächlich ist das Interesse relativ
groß man muss auch ganz klar sagen die
Fernsehsender würden nicht rund um die
Uhr berichten wenn die Einschaltquoten
nicht stimmen würde also das Interesse
ist da man muss aber sagen es ist sehr
geteilt es gibt zwar eine Mehrheit der
Amerikaner die glaubt das ist auch ein
politisches Verfahren ist aber trotzdem
gibt es auch eine Mehrheit die sagt es
ist richtig das Donald Trump angeklagt
ist niemand steht über dem Gesetz und
das muss der Rechtsstaat ja jetzt
beweisen und dafür ist das Verfahren da
und wie ist die Stimmung in New York
vor Ort gegen ihn sind dort
ja also ich würde mal sagen es ist sehr
viel mehr medienauflauf hier als
Demonstranten und es gibt ja einen
kleinen Park gegenüber vom Gericht dann
haben wir geschätztes ungefähr zwei 300
Demonstranten pro Trump und gegen Trump
die sind durch abspecke davon einander
getrennt die Polizei hat das relativ
relax gesehen es ist also nicht so ein
großer Aufmarsch wie wir uns das
erwartet hatten oder wie viele vermutet
hatten die Trump Anhänger sind nicht in
großer Zahl hierher gekommen es gibt
allerdings dann in den Straßen doch
immer relativ viele Trump Gegner die
sagen niemand steht über dem Gesetz und
skandieren das hier überall aber
insgesamt bleibt es jetzt ziemlich ruhig
danke dir für die Einschätzung unserer
Korrespondenten in New York Johannes
Hano vielen Dank bis hierhin und wir
warten jetzt gemeinsam wir warten
gemeinsam genau auf jetzt die
Anklagepunkte dass wir dann auch
wirklich wissen welche 34 das sind worum
es da genau geht ich behalte das für
euch im Blick noch ist nichts zu sehen
tatsächlich sondern einfach nur ein
Lehrer Gang und wir erwarten also darauf
und gehen für euch live drauf haben aber
also jetzt noch ein bisschen Zeit auch
zu Zeichen noch mit einem Experten den
wir uns eingeladen haben bei uns ist
us-rechtswissenschaftler Kirk Juncker
von der Uni Köln hallo schönen guten Tag
Herr Junker gut dass Sie bei uns sind
hallo guten Tag Frau Jürgen vielen Dank
Herr Junker sie warten auch mit uns
gespannt dass wir das ganze natürlich
analysieren können für die Userinnen und
User aber wir wissen jetzt also es sind
34 Anklage Punkte die verlesen worden
sind heißt das dann jetzt auch ganz
unten unmittelbar es kommt direkt jetzt
auch zum Prozess wie wird das Ganze
jetzt weiter ablaufen
nein ähm wir müssen ich glaube statt in
unsere Trump lernt Zusammenhang Denken
in New York denken was für ein straf äh
Richter wie es aussieht er muss jeden
Tag ins Büro gehen und vor den Gericht
gehen und diese Frau ist nur eine von
viele was er hat also ins zwischen ähm
was heute passiert hat und den Prozess
kommt dann wahrscheinlich viele Anträge
viele Anträge wir haben gerade jetzt
gehört vielleicht wegen den geschwörner
Anträge auf Untersuchung von Aussagen
welche andere Anträge Untersuchung der
Identifizierung wirklich auf einen
Telefongespräch war
Anträge auf Einschränkung der
Beweismittel und die können Monaten
dauern
Trump wird damit Zeit kaufen er braucht
Zeit und hat immer diese Methode benutzt
wenn er in juristische
Probleme wenn er juristische Probleme
hat hat er immer Zeit gekauft um das
benutzen zu können um mehr Beweis zu
haben oder irgendwas anderes also das
wäre dann sein Hintergrund warum er das
oder was während der konkrete Nutzen für
ihn wenn er sich Zeit kaufen könnte
warum möchte er das machen er ist immer
noch Kandidat für den
bundespräsidentschaft und je nähere
daran sind dann hat er vielleicht eine
Ausrede wir wissen dass zum Beispiel
als wir den den
Justizministerium Bericht gehabt haben
die hatten auch genug Beweismittel
gehabt aber wahrscheinlich straff
Taten zu beweisen aber dann war es
berichtet dass seit Richard Nixon
aus Politik war es entschieden und es
ist entschieden worden von den
Justizministerium nicht gegen einen
sitzender Präsident ein Strafprozess zu
führen wenn er wieder gewählt ist dann
vielleicht werden wir noch mal das sehen
ja alles klar ich habe gerade gedacht
ich hör sie nicht mehr gut aber ich
glaube es ist alles in Ordnung und
natürlich jetzt die Frage die dann auch
alle interessiert ich weiß das ist noch
Zukunftsmusik aber wie hoch sind denn
die Chancen dass Trump dann auch in so
einem Verfahren verurteilt werden würde
also in wirklich ins Gefängnis müsste
wie stehen da die Chancen ja ich glaube
wir haben eine Hinweise lässt sich ja
eigentlich bekommen von Alvin Break auch
in Prag an diese Frau lässt sich ja
gegen trumporganisation Trump
Organisation ist den schirmname für alle
sein Business und ganz ganz ist der
Leitende Oberstaatsanwalt das nur kurz
für alle die da jetzt nicht so im Thema
sind genau okay Entschuldigung ja das
war 2022 der selbe Staatsanwalt erhob in
derselben Gericht 17 Anklagepunkte wegen
betrügerische Geschäftsunterlagen aber
gegen Trump Organisation nicht gegen
Trump persönlich
der Prozess dauert sechs Wochen glaube
ich die Jury befand sich
trump-organisation in alle Anklagepunkte
beschuldigen und der Buchhalter Herr
weißer Berg sitzt nun noch im Gefängnis
nach diesem Fall nach diesem Prozess hat
er denn bei gesagt das falsche
und ich glaube das war ein Hinweis das
wir sprechen zu oft von das stomide ein
ein Pornostar ist oder Keramic dugo in
Playboy ein
in Playboy ein Marl war das hat nichts
damit zu tun versprechen jetzt schon von
businessbetrug und
steuerbetrüge und Break hat diese
Verbindung schon letztes Jahr uns
hingewiesen und ich glaube das wird
könnten wir nicht aus musste aber aus
Hinweis benutzen umzusetzen was in den
nächsten sechs bis fünf Monaten
passieren kann sie haben zwei Frauen
angesprochen eine die Waren in meiner
Anmoderation auch schon Thema die
Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels mit der
soll Trump Sex gehabt haben und eben von
dann soll dieses schweige Geld geflossen
sein aber sie haben gerade noch eine
zweite Frau Karen du Google erwähnen
können Sie dazu noch ein paar Sätze mehr
sagen
gleiche Geschichte mit Carol mit tugo
wir haben aber von denen die kleine
Detail die wir schon andere Sendungen
nicht wissenschaftlich jetzt in den
letzten zehn Minuten gesehen habe es
geht nicht um nicht nur um stomide
sondern zwei Frauen ich kann nur mir
vorstellen dass das die zweite Kerl mit
Google ist und das das ist quasi ein
musste eine verfrorentheorie wurde
bedeuten er versucht dann durch diese
diese Muskel von von Geschäft ähm seinen
Wahlkampf gewinnen zu können und das
heißt es hat nicht noch mal nichts mit
mit ob er Sex mit diese zwei Frauen hat
sondern
ob er dann Leute bezahlt haben um seinen
Wahlkampf weiter zu führen und das ist
illegal das das wäre dann er hat sein
Geschäft benutzt um seinen Wahlkampf
kämpft
ein Vorteil zu geben das ist illegal es
hat nichts mit Sex zu tun genau und
darum geht es heute wir sind also
gespannt was im Einzelnen die 34
Anklagepunkte sind ich habe hier einen
zweiten Bildschirm wo ich immer drauf
Schiele dass wir die Pressekonferenz
dazu nicht verpassen noch sieht es so
aus als hätten wir ein bisschen Zeit ich
würde also jetzt mal so mutig sein und
auch noch einen Beitrag zeigen wollen
falls in der Zwischenzeit die
Pressekonferenz losgeht würde ich den
aber unterbrechen denn gegen Trump
laufen noch ein paar mehr Ermittlungen
und einige davon sind auch sehr bekannt
und sehr Aufsehen erregend und darüber
könnten wir auch noch sprechen schauen
uns aber erstmal diese Zusammenfassung
dazu an von Alexandra haflin
eins ganz oben scheint es für ihn nur
noch abwärts zu gehen im Sog der Justiz
denn gegen Donald Trump wird von allen
Seiten ermittelt in fast zwei Dutzend
Fällen vier strafrechtliche
Untersuchungen könnten besonders
gefährlich finden werden da sind zum
einen die Ermittlungen der
Staatsanwältin in Georgia wegen
Wahlbeeinflussung bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 fehlen Trump
in dem Bundesstaat nur knapp 12.000
Stimmen zum Sieg er will um jeden Preis
im Weißen Haus bleiben und greift zum
Hörer versucht Georgias Innenminister
einen Republikaner dazu zu bringen ihn
Trump zum Sieger zu machen
ich will einfach nur
11.780 Stimmen finden eine mehr als wir
haben weil wir den Staat gewonnen haben
hat sich Trump beim Versuch die Wahl zu
kippen strafbar gemacht zu dieser Frage
hat eine Grand Jury vor kurzem ihren
Bericht abgeschlossen jetzt muss die
Staatsanwältin in Atlanta entscheiden ob
Anklage erhoben wird
eine weitere Untersuchung zur Wahl 2020
die Attacke aufs us-kapitol am 6 Januar
stürmt ein wütender Mob das
Kongressgebäude um die Bestätigung von
Joe Biden zum neuen Präsidenten zu
verhindern
angestachelt von Donald Trump
wir gehen zum Capitol und wir werden
kämpfen wie der Teufel
welche Rolle spielte Trump beim sechsten
januar und wie hat er versucht das
Wahlergebnis zu fälschen das
Justizministerium hat einen
Sonderermittler in der Sache beauftragt
dieser Sonderermittler befasst sich noch
mit einem weiteren Fall marellago
FBI-Agenten durchsuchen im vergangenen
August Trumps Anwesen in Florida und
finden diverse Geheimdokumente manche
top secret mindestens 15 Kisten mit
Unterlagen hatte das Nationalarchiv aus
Marmelade schon geborgen hat Trump im
Umgang mit den Dokumenten die nationale
Sicherheit gefährdet das
Justizministerium ermittelt und
schließlich der aktuelle Fall des
Staatsanwalts in Manhattan der Anklage
erhoben hat in einem Video an seine
Anhänger streitet Trump alles ab
[Musik]
diese vier schrecklichen Ermittlungen
der linksradikalen Demokraten gegen
euren lieblingspräsidenten ist nur die
Fortsetzung der ekelhaftesten Hexenjagd
in der Geschichte unseres Landes
alle Vorwürfe gegen ihn für Trump nichts
als Fake News
neben der aktuellen Anklage also drei
Ermittlungen die besonders herausstechen
einmal die Regierungsdokumente in seinem
privaten Anwesen dann die Frage ob er
versucht hat wahlbeamt in Georgia zu
beeinflussen und eben natürlich auch die
Rolle beim Sturm auf das us-kapitol am 6
Januar 21 warum also Herr Junker jetzt
diese im Vergleich sagen wir jetzt mal
eher kleine kleine Sache kleine Anklage
warum warum kam die jetzt zuerst im
Vergleich zu diesen drei großen
Ermittlungen die dann natürlich auch
noch im Raum stehen ja also vielleicht
erst ein paar Worte zur US federalismus
ist das anders als in Deutschland also
was die Bundesbehörden machen in den USA
ist ist anders und unabhängige von was
die die Länder machen also was sind
solche gemacht wird und was in New York
gemacht ist und was die Bundesbehörden
in Florida oder oder
mit mit mit den Kapitel in Worten sind
getrennt
dann würde ich sagen wie wie ich ein
bisschen früher gesagt haben ich glaube
Staatsanwalt in in Manhattan hat und
schon diese kleine Hinweis gegeben die
zwei Fälle gegen trumporganisation in
2022 und gegen Trump persönlich in 2003
und 20 sind für ihn zwei kippen aus den
gleichen Busch also ich glaube
Beweismittel wird dann wahrscheinlich in
2022 schon gesammelt und er hat jetzt
die Gelegenheit diese Beweismittel zu
benutzen
warum nicht er hat schon Erfolg gehabt
das war auch eine Überraschung dass er
gegen den Trump Organisation gewonnen
haben hat viele haben erwartet dass oh
das ist Donald Trump oder seine
Organisation dass keiner hat er hat auch
keine Chance in dem Fall gewinnen zu
können aber hat er und deswegen glaube
ich dass ähm wir sehen das jetzt erst
die anderen waren bis zum vielleicht die
bessere Beweismittel haben oder was weiß
ich ähm ich habe eine Allergie die diese
Woche gehört also wie wenn man bei ein
Buch geht niemand möchte erster hingehen
aber wenn der erste da geht dann kommen
alle die andere dahinter okay schauen
wir mal warten wir mal ab ob das so ist
jetzt zu aktuellen Anklage den aktuellen
Anklage Punkten gibt es Fragen bei uns
im Stream einmal möchte Meister bei
Youtube wissen wie werden die
Konsequenzen für Trump aussehen
und dran auf leider wissen wir immer
noch nicht was genau in diese 34
Anklagepunkte geschrieben ist
vermutlich
es geht auf zwei verschiedene Stufen
erstens dass er diesen zwei Frauen oder
mindestens Story der News das Geld
bezahlt hat das war ihm gewusst das kann
Michael Cohen beweisen und dann zweitens
ein eins zweite Straftat er hat es
gemacht absichtlich kurz vor den Wahl um
seine Chancen in diesem Wald verbessern
zu können und das ist dann in dem Sinn
wurde interpretiert als ob es ein
Spender an seine eigene Wahlkampf war
und diese zwei Strafe zusammen könnte
bedeuten ein was sie merkanen ein
verlängerin nennen ein Straftat und
solch ein Straftat in New York könnte
bis zum 4 Jahren gefäng NIS bedeuten das
beantwortet vielleicht jetzt auch die
Frage von friederiko Montana der fragte
nämlich was wäre ein realistisches
Strafmaß für Trump also vier Jahre wir
haben es gerade gehört könnte das
bedeuten Emmanuel Machado bei Youtube
fragt uns was hätte es für Auswirkungen
auf das amerikanische Justizsystem wenn
ein ehemaliger Präsident verurteilt wird
ich finde es eigentlich positiv wie ihr
der Kollege in New York und schon
erwähnt hat er ist nicht unbedingt
gesetzt dann
auch wenn er Präsident ist in
Zusammenhang mit mit anderen Ländern
zwar kursieren Frankreich perisconi in
Italien
nessun Yahoo Israel Lulu jetzt in in
Venezuela es gibt viele stadtschiffe
oder Chefinnen die schon verhaftet waren
oder im Gefängnis waren es ist nicht
außerordentlich nur für den USA ich
finde das juristisch überhaupt
unproblematisch jetzt ist bei Trump
natürlich das spannende er war bereits
einmal US-Präsident er würde es aber
gerne wieder werden
2024 wird in den USA gewählt und dazu
passt jetzt die Frage von USA Ronaldo
Drums kann ein verurteilter Straftäter
in den USA ein öffentliches Amt antreten
bevor die Strafe geküsst wurde ja
kein Problem wir haben zwei Beispiele
die wir benutzen könnten in 1994 der
Bürgermeister in Washington DC Mariann
Berry war verhaftet war verurteilt saß
im Gefängnis wegen Kokain besitzt und
wieder gewährt also daraus kam und dann
20 Jahre später in Louisiana der
gouvernor Edwin average war dann auch
wegen
organisatorische Kriminalität verhaftet
verurteilt saß im Gefängnis kam raus und
dann hat den Wahlkampf für den
bundes-residentenhaus
erfolgreich
geführt am Ende des Tages war er dann in
den letzten Punkt dann ist er nicht
gewählt aber hat er gemacht also erst
erlaubt könnte gut sein
die neueste Meldung die wir übrigens
bekommen haben ist dass die
Pressekonferenz auf die wir ja auch noch
warten in acht Minuten losgehen soll das
will ich euch nur kurzuren als
Zwischenstand aber es gibt ja wirklich
noch genug Spannendes über das wir
sprechen können ganz einfach ist es auch
nicht manchmal zu verstehen da sind ja
wirklich einige Anschuldigungen jetzt im
Vorfeld schon im Raum von denen wir also
wissen und was jetzt aber weil wir auch
gerade beim Thema sind ja noch ganz
spannend ist also Trump ist ja im
Zweifel vielleicht auch dazu in der Lage
diese ganze den Medien Rummel sagen
jetzt mal so weil das haben wir jetzt
schon gesehen der Medien Rummel ist groß
das Ganze für sich zu nutzen also er
schrieb auch selbst bei seiner Plattform
tschüss social ich lese mal kurz vor vor
zwei Stunden hat er da geschrieben er
fährt jetzt nach lower man hätten und es
scheint ihm surreal wow sie werden mich
ah ihr seht jetzt auch hier auf meinem
Bildschirm das doch super genau also er
schreibt wow der going to restmee also
sie werden mich festnehmen can't believe
das ist happening in America make
America great again also hier auch
wieder seinen Slogan und er bringt sich
da ja ein bisschen in eine Rolle ruft
auch immer wieder zu Spenden auf wegen
dieser ganzen
gerichtlichen Verfolgung die er da jetzt
in dir da jetzt rein geraten ist so und
jetzt aber zu meiner Frage nutzt die
Anklage vielleicht sogar Trumps Ansehen
bei seinen Anhängern was glauben Sie
daher junger schadet ihm das oder nützt
ihm das
seine Gruppe von Anhängern ist nicht so
groß wie Leute oftmals denken und sie
werden auch wenn er doch in und Schiff
habe nur jemand erschossen hat
wahrscheinlich in wählen diese Gruppe
bleibt immer traue treu bei ihm dass das
das müssen wir einfach zugeben andere
Leute die in der Mitte sind bei solche
Dinge sind nicht überzeugt er baut Geld
natürlich braucht er Geld er hat wie sie
gerade jetzt uns gezeigt haben viele
Fälle die vor Gericht in bringen könnte
und er braucht dafür für jeder dann
Georgia Anwälte New York Anwälte
Bundesanwälte das kostet viel aber das
das bedeutet nicht dass nur durch wird
erwidert nein das geht nicht
wir reden hier ja über hypothetisch was
natürlich passieren könnte und dazu
passt auch die Frage von Ben BM bei
Youtube er fragt sich kann er
theoretisch aus dem Gefängnis heraus
wieder Präsident werden
ja
komischerweise er darf nicht selber
wählen aber er darf Präsident
okay kurze klare Antwort und gefragt
sich der User die Userin was ist ihre
Einschätzung wie die Anklage
weiterverlaufen wird also da natürlich
auch jetzt ein großes Interesse wie geht
das jetzt ganz konkret weiter
es wird
Monaten dauern vielleicht länger
ich
wurde die Warnung geben es wird
wahrscheinlich langweilig also wir
werden wie gesagt früher am viele
Anträge hören die ein bisschen technisch
Klingen werden und nicht nicht sexy wie
storny Daniels oder Donald Trump selber
also es wird sehr technisch sehr
juristisch und sehr langweilig
wahrscheinlich in der Mitte Zeit bis zum
diese Prozess geführt wird wenn ein
Prozess geführt wird vielleicht eine von
dieser Anträge erfolgreich wird und dann
haben wir kein Prozess oder vielleicht
geht der bis zum diese Prozess und sieht
er kann nicht er wird verlieren und dann
ein privatgrundpunkt werden wir sehen
aber es kommt nicht morgen es kommt
nicht nächste Woche also wir müssen
wirklich jetzt alle Geduld haben
und Trump sieht sich da also als Opfer
das hat er schon ziemlich klar gemacht
denn er hat auch zum Beispiel über den
Richter in dieser Sache gesagt der würde
ihn hassen also da ist die Frage wie zum
Beispiel auch hier von User Emanuel
Machado der fragt sind die Anklagen
politisch motiviert das suggeriert ja
Trump auch ein wenig damit das ist eine
Art Hetzjagd ist die dagegen eingeführt
wird das kommt ja häufiger was würden
Sie darauf antworten ja also wir haben
diese Geschichte schon seit 4 Jahren
gehört jedes Mal wenn irgendwas gegen
Donald Trump kommt sagt er das Wort
Hexenjagd er meinte dass alles was
negativ ist muss nur positiv werden dass
das ist einfach nicht der Fall ähm diese
Richter ist berühmt für beide Seiten
Verteidiger und und Staatsanwaltschaft
alles sehr fair sehr ordentlich und sehr
business like ist ich glaube New York
hat ihn deswegen
gewählten genommen für diesen Fall
wir rücken jetzt der 21:45 Uhr ein
bisschen näher noch zwei Minuten
vielleicht können Sie uns auch kurz noch
weil sie sich besonders auskennen auch
etwas sagen über den Leitenden
Oberstaatsanwalt wir hatten ihn schon
kurz angesprochen Alvin Break er wird
vermutlich auch der sein den wir gleich
hören werden wir uns also aufklären wird
über die 34 Anklage Punkte was ist das
für eine Alvin Break den wir also gleich
hoffentlich dann auch hören und sehen
werden
ja also erst vielleicht müssen wir
erinnern dass in den USA die
Staatsanwalt sie sind normalerweise auch
gewählt
und er ist keine Überraschung von den
Demokraten demokratische Partei und
deswegen meintet Herr Trump und alle
Leute mit fröhlich muss das dann nur ein
politischer Hexenjagd sein er hat ein
ein sehr starker
solider ruft und wie gesagt sagte zur
Zeit ähm letzten
seit 2022 hatte erfolgreich gegen den
trumporganisation ein Strafprozess
geführt und ich glaube dass ein guten
Hinweis was wir erwarten können es gibt
übrigens jetzt auch schon erste Meldung
machen wir vielleicht einen kleinen
Vorgriff was da jetzt also drin stehen
könnte in den Anklagen Punkten eine
Eilmeldung die soeben reinkamen lautet
Trump wegen Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen angeklagt ist das
das was sie uns auch schon versucht
haben zu erklären am Anfang also geht es
da dann um den Fall von stormy Daniels
und eventuell einer zweiten Frau und
alles was da eben noch mit dranhängen
ist das damit gemeint genau so ist es
wie gesagt also es ist mehr
interessant vielleicht von dieser Frauen
zu sprechen natürlich Sie die Bilder von
von stormy Daniels oder im Playboy Model
es interessante als
geschäftsbildung zu benutzen aber es hat
nichts mit Frauen oder Sex zu tun es hat
mit Business und und und Steuerbetrug
und Business Betrug zu tun und deswegen
sollen wir ich sagte diesen Fall von
für Kupplung mit was jetzt passiert hat
ist das eigentlich auch relevant wie
lange das ganze schon her ist weil das
ist ja jetzt eine Geschichte die ist ja
wirklich schon ein paar Jahre alt
ist aber seine seine Vorgänger so von
von Alvin bryk seine Amt hat das der
zombie-file Zombie Fall genannt weil das
immer noch lebt und die könnten nicht
entscheiden ob sie das bringen sollen
oder nicht bringen sollen Bike hat die
Entscheidung gemacht ja wir haben genug
Beweismittel wir machen es weiter am es
gibt ein sogenannter Zeitgrenze ein
statations aber in New York wenn jemand
aus
vermutlicher Verteidiger außer New York
wohnt für eine längere Zeit in den oder
für Donald Trump in Florida dann gibt's
einen eine Pause in dieser diese diese
Zeitgrenze diese Zeichnung damit und
eine Sache die ich auch noch besonders
spannend fand wäre mir schon ein
bisschen versucht mit ihnen in die
Zukunft zu schauen da sagten sie es gilt
als ziemlich sicher dass Trump also
versuchen wird das Verfahren in die
Länge zu ziehen warum genau würde ihm
das nutzen
es ist normalerweise ein ein
Vorteil für jede Verteidiger es ist
nicht besonders mit Donald Trump und
eine von ihrer Zuschauern hat früher
geschrieben inwieweit geht es um Geld am
er hat in dem sie ein Vorteil wir können
mehr Anwälte bezahlen um irgendwie durch
ihre Untersuchung durch ihre Forschung
Methode zu finden mehr Anträge zu
stellen
Zeit zu kaufen ist immer wichtig für ein
Verteidiger in der Zwischenzeit sitzt er
immer Lager macht er seinen Wahlkampf
das ist sehr wichtig oder wenn es ja
noch weitergeht als nur Wahlkampf auch
eine hypothetische Frage von User Ben
bei Youtube fragt er kann er sich später
als Präsident wenn er das denn noch mal
werden sollte selbst begnadigen nein
bis das er kann jeder andere in in der
bundespräsern aber ich habe früher
gesagt also was sind deutsche passieren
könntet was jetzt schon heute in New
York bis hier hat die sind
länderprobleme und ein Präsident kann
nicht er hat nichts miteinander
zu tun er könnte andere Leute von von
Bundesstraßen dann begnadigen aber nicht
Länder
okay ich schaue noch mal hier in eure
Kommentare ihr habt Glück es verzögert
sich also scheinbar ein bisschen wir
haben schon 21:47 Uhr heißt aber klar
mehr Zeit für Fragen außerdem haben sich
auch die Anwälte von Donald Trump
geäußert und das können wir euch dann
hoffentlich auch gleich zeigen das
machen wir für euch jetzt bereit aber
erst noch mal kurz zu euren Fragen
Manchester United der oder die Userin
fragt sich wie werden die Richter in den
USA für bestimmte Fälle ausgewählt und
dann schließe ich gerne an vielleicht
jetzt auch ganz konkret wie wurde der
Richter für diesen Fall ausgewählt ähm
es kommt irgendwann auf in in äh nicht
nur in New York also Bundesland sondern
in Manhattan also wir müssen mal
vorstellen ein Richter aus ein
Mitarbeiter er oder sie sitzt in einem
Büro mit 20 andere Richtung Richterinnen
und sie machen einfach einen Kreis je
nachdem einen neuen Fall kommt wer ist
jetzt dran das das war willkürlich das
ist gar kein Plan dafür
und noch eine weitere Frage die wird
jetzt ein bisschen weg von jetzt dem
reinen faktischen was da im Gerichtssaal
passiert aber ist natürlich nicht
weniger spannend User Sven uden da oben
oder Tal so heißt er bei Facebook fragt
wie sehr wird mit einer Eskalation am
Rande der Anklageerhebung in der Nacht
gerechnet also wie sehr glauben Sie Herr
Junker wird das wieder die Stimmung
Aufheizen in den USA wie sehr wird das
Spalten
politisch natürlich es ist
wird immer noch von von die Anhängern
aus Hexenjagd aus rein politisch aus
unfair und so weiter und so fort aber
ich glaube die die die Mehrheit nach
Umfrage was für eine letzte Woche
gesehen haben die Mehrheit denken wenn
es gibt genug Beweismittel soll das dann
passieren
ich glaube es ist
es geht nicht nur um Politik es könnte
um Politik gehen aber es ist wirklich
die Frage wie ihr Kollege in New York
schon Projekte hat ob irgendjemand auch
Donald Trump auch ein Bundespräsident
über den Gesetz ist
es gibt noch eine weitere Frage von
einem User einer Userin
Jay jambjmb könnte die Trump
Organisation Trump Organisation als Rico
Fall sage ich das überhaupt richtig Rico
als Rico Fall angeklagt werden
Kriminalität in den USA
ich
könnte sein weiß nicht also das hat aber
nicht in den Fall
2022 das war wegen genau wie bei Donald
Trump äh Paragraph 175 und
Strafgesetzbuch in New York es ist wegen
ähm die Unterlagen die Unterlagen das
war und äh etwas mit Steuer hat es zu
tun mit mit den äh Trump Organisation
aber nicht mit Rewe
und dann aber was ich auch nicht
uninteressant finde wenn wir jetzt uns
den Prozess noch mal anschauen
vielleicht auch Unterschiede die es
geben könnte zu jetzt so einem ähnlichen
Prozess in Deutschland da gibt es von
einem User der auch hier richtig rege
dabei ist und viele Fragen stellt
deswegen nehme ich gerne noch mal eine
Emanuel Machado fragt was müsste beim
Prozess passieren damit Trump verurteilt
wird also wie genau ist dieser Prozess
gestaltet und was eben genau müsste
passieren dass das dann am Ende auch so
ausgeht ja also die Staatsanwaltschaft
hat schon entschieden was sie als
Beweismittel haben für alle diese vier
und dreckige Anklage Punkte und die
müssen dann ihre Beweise vor den Gericht
vor den geschorener werden wenn ein Jury
gibt eine Jury gibt ähm und dann
nachdem der Richter wird dann die schöne
gibt erklären was ist juristisch
bedeutet und wenn Sie glauben zum
Beispiel von diese Beweismittel dann
schon absichtlich bezahlt hat und die
wählen zu betrügen dann müssen sie
finden das dass gegen das new Orgas
Gesetz widrig ist
ja
während wir hier immer noch warten
langsam zieht sich natürlich ein
bisschen ich hoffe ihr bleibt noch
interessiert weiter dabei können wir mal
gemeinsam auf meinen Bildschirm schauen
denn inzwischen gibt es auf jeden Fall
schon mal eine Presse Mitteilung
schriftlich ein presses Statement obwohl
wir natürlich immer noch auf das ja
Videos Statement warten und hier sehen
wir jetzt also auch wirklich noch mal
schwarz auf weiß ich markiere es mal die
Bestätigung er ist also in 34 Punkten
angeklagt Herr Junker können sie
eigentlich auch gerade mein Bildschirm
sehen schon ne das ist so klein kann ich
nicht meine eigene danke schön
nee das ist schon in Ordnung genau also
hier haben wir schon mal das
schriftliche Statement möchte ist aber
natürlich auch gerne gleich noch mal mit
auch den Presse Fragen die
wahrscheinlich kommen werden von den
Journalisten und Journalisten hören aber
hier könnt ihr schon mal sehen könnte es
euch natürlich auch selber anschauen im
Netz ist das auch natürlich zugänglich
für euch alle und ich schau noch mal
ganz kurz ob ihr Fragen habt oder ob ihr
hoffentlich noch nicht eingeschlafen
seid ist er jetzt sogar bei uns schon
auch heute journal Zeit also bleibt
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen hier
und zwar sich hier noch eine Frage von
Christian K wohl und zwar fragt
Christian sich würden sie eher von einer
Bewährung Geld oder Haftstrafe ausgehen
kann ich nicht sagen weil wir immer noch
nicht diese 34 Anklagepunkte gesehen
haben
Geld hat auch den Trump Organisation in
2022 bezahlt
1,7 Millionen aber das klingt viel für
uns alltägliche Leute aber für den Trump
Organisation war das Peanuts das war wie
ein wie ein ein eine
verkehrstrasse ein Verkehr und und
Herr Junker sie sind so nett und bleiben
natürlich bei uns ich komme auch gleich
wieder zu Ihnen zurück für die Analyse
sowieso auch natürlich wenn die
Pressekonferenz mit der
Oberstaatsanwaltschaft endlich losgeht
aber wir haben auch noch unsere Kollegin
in Washington zugeschaltet denn wieder
wie die Reaktionen natürlich in
Washington sind das ist auch interessant
für uns und wir können jetzt hoffentlich
zu Alexandra Haflinger und da sehen wir
sie auch schon schalten hallo Alexandra
schön dass du bei uns bist
hallo Alisa Alexandra du hast dir sogar
auch schon du hattest die Zeit dir das
Papier auch schon durchzulesen was war
jetzt ein Punkt für dich der besonders
auch herausgestochen ist
also durchzulesen ist zu viel gesagt
aber überflogen es sind 15 Seiten die
Anklageschrift ist seit wenigen Minuten
öffentlich also zuvor wussten wir ja
überhaupt nicht was genau Trump
vorgeworfen wird und wenn ich jetzt mal
drauf gucke es sind wie wir schon gesagt
haben 34 Anklagepunkte eine ganze Menge
es geht im Wesentlichen darum was Trump
vorgeworfen wird ist die Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen und es wird ihm
vorgeworfen dass aus dem Grund gemacht
zu haben seine Kandidatur damals 2016
promote zu haben ne aus diesem Gründen
ähm und im Zentrum stehen auch die
schweigegeldzahlungen gegen zwei Frauen
das hatten ähm hattet ihr ja schon
besprochen genau
[Musik]
Trump hat ja auf nicht schuldig plädiert
in allen Anklagepunkten und die Anwälte
haben auch schon angekündigt sie hatten
vorhin gegenüber CNN auch schon gesagt
sie werden sich darum bemühen dass alle
Anklagepunkte fallen gelassen werden wir
haben das Statement von den Anwälten von
Donald Trump jetzt auch vorliegen können
das uns gemeinsam anschauen und dann
drüber sprechen
[Musik]
das nichts faktisches drinstehen würde
so die Anwälte von Trump und dass sie
das ganze natürlich bekämpfen wollen hat
man denn jetzt von Trump selbst schon
was gehört Alex wir hatten kurz am
Anfang darüber gesprochen mit Johannes
da hatte Trump noch nicht selbst gesagt
hast du da jetzt inzwischen mehr gehört
andere Infos
also zunächst einmal haben wir Fotos
gesehen von dem Moment als Trump dem
Richter vorgeführt wurde seine Miene
wirkte zumindest sehr ernst und er sehr
versteinert und wir haben es auch gerade
gehört die Anwälte meinten Trump ist
einfach frustriert und ab Set also nicht
gerade in der in der besten Stimmung
wie wir es auch gerade jetzt gehört
haben die Anwälte tun alles ab sie sehen
die Anklage und die Ermittlungen als
politisch motiviert nehmen das nicht
ernst und Trump und auch die Anwälte
Räumen keinen Fehlverhalten ein und gibt
es überhaupt jetzt schon auch erste
Reaktionen Washington also erstmal
natürlich von der US-Regierung von Joe
bei selbst
also unmittelbar auf die einzelnen
Anklagepunkte habe ich jetzt noch nichts
gesehen an Reaktionen aber was wir
wissen ist dass Joe Biden der Präsident
so ziemlich das gleiche macht wie ich
gerade also von Washington aus das
Geschehen in New York zu beobachten
allerdings hat seine Pressesprecherin
heute betont dass darauf nicht sein
Fokus liegt die Strategie von Joe Biden
war schon in den letzten Tagen also
immer wieder von Reportern auf die
Anklage gegen Trump angesprochen wurde
Strategie von beiden ist no comment kein
Kommentar das Weiße Haus und Joe beiden
man will sich nicht zu einem laufenden
Verfahren äußern gestern aus Minnesota
bei einem Termin hatte beiden gesagt er
habe vollstes Vertrauen in die New
Yorker Polizei das alles ruhig bleiben
wird und auch in das Rechtssystem
und gibt es aber Reaktionen von jetzt
führenden republikanerinnen oder
Republikanern von vielleicht aber auch
gerade Trump sehr wohlgesonnen
Republikanern republikanerinnen
da gab es eine ganze Menge also schon
bevor eben die genauen anklungen
Anklagepunkte öffentlich waren haben sie
sich auf Trumps Seite geschlagen eine
sehr
berühmte
Abgeordnete des Repräsentantenhaus
Materie Taylor green sie ist Trump sehr
wohlgesonnen und verbreitet sehr häufig
Verschwörungstheorien sie war heute in
New York hat an einer Demonstration für
Trump teilgenommen hat seine
unschuldbeteuert und auch der
Vorsitzende des Repräsentanten Hauses
Kevin McCarthy ähm hat gesagt es ist ein
Skandal das gegen Donald Trump ermittelt
wird und hat angekündigt eine
Untersuchung
des Kongresses einzuleiten
aber nicht nur die Republikaner die
bekanntlich Trump wohlgesonnen sind auch
Partei eine Konkurrenten haben sich auf
die Seite von Trump geschlagen darunter
Mike Pence sein ehemaliger Vize der auch
als Präsidentschaftskandidat antreten
will
hat den hat die Staatsanwaltschaft
angegriffen hat ihr Amtsmissbrauch
vorgeworfen und auch run the Säntis der
Gouverneur von Florida der ja als
größter Konkurrent derzeit gilt im
Präsidentschaft im Rennen um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur obwohl rondes
noch nicht öffentlich
verkündet hat dass er den antreten will
auch rendessen hat sich zu Wort gemeldet
was interessant war ist das
jedem Republikaner
dem ist gerade geraten sich auf Trumps
Seite zu stellen
wenn nicht dann erntet man viele
Minuspunkte und auch Donald tr UMP
postet regelmäßig auf Youtube social und
setzt auch jeden unter Druck der sich
nicht direkt auf öffentlich auf seine
Seite stellt wie er es schon mit run the
Säntis gemacht hat der anfangs 48
Stunden sich in schweigent hatte
es gibt auch natürlich die Frage hier
bei uns von den Usern nicht nur wie
äußert sich die Politik sondern ein User
eine Userin mit dem fantastischen Namen
gern weggetreten übrigens hoffe ich dass
ihr das noch nicht seid fragt sich wie
ist die Stimmung auf der Straße jetzt
kannst du natürlich über Washington vor
allem berichten und auch über die die
Tage jetzt davor also was hält der oder
die Amerikanerin davon
ähm genau also wie die Stimmung ist habe
ich auch nur gesehen aus aus Livebildern
in New York ich glaube an dich meine ich
glaube der User meint das grundsätzlich
also wie stehen die Amerikanerin
Amerikaner grundsätzlich jetzt zu diesem
Medienspektakel und auch natürlich zu
der Anklage und dem weiteren Vorgehen
also es ist ein großes Medienspektakel
das hatte Johannes Hano ja
dargestellt ist es ist einfach
historisch dass ein ehemaliger Präsident
sich eine Anklage stellen muss
es gibt Umfragen die von CNN in Auftrag
gegeben wurden laut dessen den Umfragen
finden 60% der Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikaner ist gut dass Anklage gegen
Trump erhoben wird allerdings was auch
interessant ist drei Viertel der
Befragten sagen auch dass sie die
Anklage durchaus als politisch motiviert
sehen ähm genau das hatten wir vorhin
auch schon mal als Thema das es
natürlich auch jetzt immer was was
häufiger kam jetzt in diesem ganzen
vorab schon und seit man auch von der
Anklage weiß es gibt einen User eine
Userin mit einem unaussprechlichen
Buchstabensalat Namen deswegen kann ich
das nicht sagen der oder die fragt sich
wie berichtet Fox News über den Fall ich
könnte mir vorstellen die Frage kommt
weil Fox News galt ja früher als ein
sehr pro trump-sender wobei Alex das hat
sich ja auch schon enorm geändert in den
letzten Jahren ne
in in letzter Zeit stand Fox News vor
allem in der Kritik und und auch in den
Medien weil offenkundig wurde das also
Fox News hat sich
während der der Wahl 2016 und und
nicht 2016 sondern 2020 als Trump eben
diese Lüge von der Wahl so propagiert
hat hat sich Fox News auf die Seite
Trumps gestellt hat sehr viele Gäste
Experten eingeladen und interviewt oder
auch Politiker die eben diese wahllüge
vertreten haben
intern aber hat sich bei Fox News andere
Stimmen gelegt also auch sehr bekannte
Gesichter wie takakarsen haben sich
kritisch gegenüber Trump geäußert
es ist jetzt interessant zu sehen wie
jetzt Fox News seine Berichterstattung
künftig ausrichten wird und auch wie
sich die republikanische Partei
gegenüber Trump verhält noch stehen sie
scheinbar geschlossen hinter ihm es gibt
nur sehr vereinzelte
Parteimitglieder die sich offen gegen
Trump stellen da kann man einen erwähnen
das ist der Ex Gouverneur vom
Bundesstaat Orchester Isa hutchinsons
der hatte in den letzten Tagen gesagt es
ist endlich Zeit also es ist jetzt Zeit
dass Trump zurücktritt ähm den Weg frei
macht weil die Anklage ist es einfach
too much zu viel er hat dieser
hatchimals hat aber auch ähm verkündet
dass er als Präsident also um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur ins Rennen
geht
[Musik]
okay eine Frage die wir mit Junker auch
schon besprochen haben aber dafür nicht
deine Einschätzung natürlich auch
spannend und die kam jetzt auch noch mal
erneut franziskus Herzog der User fragt
sich könnte Trump diesen Prozess für
seinen Wahlkampf nutzen
auf jeden Fall also wir wir haben das
gesehen in den letzten Tagen auf true
social hat er mit Videos mit Posts immer
wieder allein schon aufgerufen für
seinen Wahlkampf zu spenden und wenn man
dem Wahlkampfteam Trumps glaubt dann
sind allein seit die Anklage publik
wurde also seit dem vergangenen
Donnerstag schon 5 Millionen
US-Dollar geflossen also Trump weiß wie
man aus der Anklage Kapital schlägt und
zum anderen
inszeniert er sich als Opfer der Justiz
als ähm Opfer einer politischen
Verschwörung und das könnte ihm auch bei
seiner Basis zumindest Punkte bringen
Einschätzung von unserer Korrespondentin
in Washington von Alexandra Hafling
vielen Dank dass du dir Zeit genommen
hast und bis zum nächsten Mal
und lasst uns doch ah nein Junker ist
wieder da ist doch super ich wollte euch
gerade auch nur einfach das leere Pult
zeigen dass ihr seht dass man wirklich
nicht sieht aber Herr Junker schön dass
Sie da sind es gibt nämlich auch wieder
Fragen die ganz bestimmt hier spannend
sind wenn die wenn Sie die für uns
beantworten wobei ich sehe gerade ich
habe ja mein halbes Auge hier auf der
Pressekonferenz und vielleicht schalten
wir doch mal kurz rüber denn ich sehe da
regt sich gerade was und sonst kommen
wir gleich zurück zu Ihnen Herr Junker
genau lass uns doch mal schauen nur ich
möchte es nicht verpassen aber ich
glaube
ach das dauert immer noch man bringt
sich zwar Anstellung aber so sieht das
ich kann es euch sagen schon die ganze
Zeit so sieht das schon die ganze Zeit
aus ich glaube das neue sind jetzt
einfach nur die Tafeln die aufgebaut
worden sind der wird also wahrscheinlich
anhand der Tafeln gleich etwas erklärt
aber es ist tatsächlich noch nicht mehr
zu sehen okay das sind die Tafeln die
fotografiert werden die sind jetzt aber
so weit weg also ich kann sie nicht
erkennen dazu sind meine Augen zu
schlecht dann doch natürlich wieder
zurück zu Junker der netterweise ja noch
weiter bei uns bleibt ich habe Fragen
gesammelt bei uns im Stream und zwar hat
so seine gefragt wie wird sichergestellt
dass die Jury wenn es denn eine gibt das
haben wir ja schon gelernt dass die Jury
neutral ist überprüft man die politische
Gesinnung
wird vorher gefragt beide Seiten dürfen
dann Frage stellen und normalerweise
eine von den beiden Seiten oder beide
Seiten werden einfach fragen können Sie
diese Verteidiger ein Pferd Pfeil geben
und wenn sie ja sagen sind sie
akzeptiert manchmal denken Leute das
muss dir irgendwie anonym bleiben dass
das das ist sinnlos das wurde bedeuten
Gwyneth Paltrow oder Donald Trump
könnten nicht von Gericht gewagt werden
die brauchen also die geschirrung
brauchen nur zu sagen ja ich kann ein
Vertrag geben ich habe kein Vorurteile
und auch eine Frage die ich interessant
finde Vincent sucht fragt welche Folgen
könnte dieser Gerichtsprozess für
zukünftige oder vergangene
US-Präsidenten haben also wenn da noch
wahrscheinlich was was warten meint er
schwer zu sagen mindestens können wir
vielleicht lernen dass was ich früher
ein ein Justizministerium
Bundesjustizministerium Politik wegen
Richard Nixon das Einsetzen der
Präsident nie unter Druck von ein
Staatsanwaltschaft kommen könnte
ist vorbei vielleicht werden Sie das
ändern aber außerdem ist es zu schwer zu
sagen
wie natürlich alles jetzt gerade ein
bisschen im Ungefähren bleibt solange
wir jetzt auch nicht noch mehr gehört
haben zu den Ankleiden Klage Punkten
dass wir natürlich jetzt langsam
wirklich spannend aber ich nehme hier
gerne noch mehr Fragen mit rein die Zeit
die haben wir ja und zwar franziskus
Herzog noch mal schön wenn ihr viele
Fragen stellt ich finde es super
schreibt gibt es eine Möglichkeit das
Trump diese Situation nutzt und schluss
endlich deswegen wieder gewählt wird
gibt doch genug ähnliche Fälle jetzt ist
die Frage für mich so ein bisschen was
sind die ähnlichen Fälle da stehe ich
gerade auf dem Schlauch wie geht's Ihnen
Herr Junker
diese Frage ist oftmals gestellt und ich
frage mich wenn jemand das gestellt hat
wie wurde er es nutzen wenn er verliert
und Gefängnis sitzt das kann ich mir
vorstellen wie es irgendwie für Donald
Trump positiv wäre
in der Zwischenzeit wenn er sagt bei
jeder Antrag ja das ist noch mal ein
Hexenjagd das ist genau was wir zurzeit
haben ja könnte er dann mehr Spende
bekommen aber wie er ein ein ein wenn er
beurteilt ist wie er das Positive
benutzen könnte kann ich nicht
beantworten
wir haben aber auch noch mal ein paar
Bilder für euch dass wir hier nicht nur
reden sondern dass wir euch auch mal ein
bisschen was zeigen können Trump ist
nämlich inzwischen Weg aus New York hat
New York verlassen da können wir mal
reinschauen in Bilder er ist zum
Flughafen das sind Bilder von CNN die
wir euch jetzt zeigen können also
zumindest wissen wir er ist nicht mehr
da es war ja die ganze Zeit noch die
Frage wird es vielleicht auch noch mal
ein Statement von ihm geben aber das ist
jetzt zumindest Statement jetzt hier
heute aus New York damit ist nicht mehr
zu rechnen denn wir sehen ihn hier wenn
auch ein bisschen weit weg dass er den
Flieger bestiegen hat und wieder nach
Hause fliegt nochmal allago da ist aber
tatsächlich geplant dass er sich äußern
wird was wir gehört haben sind es wohl
500 geladene Gäste zu denen er sprechen
wird ich meine morgen soll das passieren
und was wir jetzt inzwischen auch gehört
haben ist dass der Prozess erst 2024
dann beginnen soll warum ist das so Herr
Juncker warum dauert das also dann auch
noch so eine ganze Weile
das weiß ich nicht also diese Detail
habe ich nicht gehört habe ich nicht
gelesen ich habe keine Begründung dafür
gehört tut mir leid okay ich schaue noch
mal ganz kurz in eure Fragen kleinen
Moment und zwar habt ihr jetzt auch gar
nicht mehr so viele also langsam wird es
hier länglich für uns wir sind auch
glaube ich schon seit fast einer Stunde
live ich lese aber zumindest ein kleines
Lob von Michael B das finde ich ganz
nett er schreibt er findet toll dass wir
ein amerikanischen Experten haben also
das Lob geht an Sie dass wir original
Interview Ausschnitte ohne deutschen
Untertitel oder ohne deutsche
Übersetzung gezeigt haben und auch die
Interaktion mit dem Livechat und sogar
dass duzen und das aber selten selbst
das Duzen mag er gefällt mir danke
Michael für die Blumen also wir
versuchen hier unser Bestes euch
natürlich hier auch jetzt nicht zu
langweilen weil das hier ein bisschen
dauert aber ich finde es überhaupt nicht
langweilig ich finde es klasse und es
geht los und zwar können wir jetzt live
zur Pressekonferenz schalten und dann
analysieren
heute Nachmittag wurde
dem Richter in New York vorgeführt
und es wurden 34 Anklagepunkte verlesen
und unter dem New Yorker Gesetz ist das
ein Verbrechen
Geschäftsunterlagen zu welchen das ist
ein Versuch des Betrugs und der
vertischung eines anderen Verbrechens
und darum geht es hierbei auch
es wurden falsche Erklärung abgegeben
andere Verbrechen zu vertuschen das sind
Verbrechen in New York State
egal wer man ist
und es geht hier um ernsthafte
Verbrechen die nicht normal sind
es wurden immer wieder in
Geschäftsunterlagen falsch Erklärung
abgegeben und er hat auch andere
zugebracht falsche Erklärungen abgegeben
für
anwaltliche Dienst dazu Dienstleistungen
aber das war falsch und das war eine
falsche Erklärung die immer und immer
wieder 2017 abgegeben wurde im April im
Mai im Juni und so weiter und während
des restlichen Jahres auch nein neun
Monate lang
hatte er Dokumente in seiner Hand wo
diese zentralen falsche sagen waren dass
er Michael Korn für anwaltliche
Dienstleistung 2017
für in jedem dieser neun Monate
insgesamt hat das große Geschworenen
Gericht herausgefunden dass es 34
Dokumente gab mit diesen falschen
Erklärungen warum hat Donald Trump immer
wieder diese falschen Erklärungen
abgegeben die Beweise werden zeigen dass
er das tat um Verbrechen zu vertuschen
die sich auf die Wahl 2016 bezogen
Donald Trump
als Vorsitzender einer
Mediengesellschaft und
es ist und willkommen haben sich darauf
kein Licht in einem Zuhause an Plan
negative Informationen Bezug auf die
Waffen Donald Trump zu unterdrücken und
es gab drei Zahlungen an Menschen von
denen sie ist das negative Informationen
über Donald Trump zur Verfügung hätten
um das zu machen wurden Strohfirmen
aufgebaut und es wurde noch mehr falsche
Erklärungen abgegeben zum Beispiel
in den geschäftlichen Unterlagen von ame
American Media in Corporation
Geld bezahlt an anderen Frau namens da
mit der Nils zwei Wochen vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl hat mal gekonnt und
das was sie tausend Dollar an den
Rechtsanwalt sonst nur mit denen jetzt
überwiesen das wird Zahlung
ist eine Information gewesen die von den
Wählern weggehalten wurde dies ist
Schema dieser Plan war illegal hat das
Recht das war recht verletzt
und die 130.000
Dollar Überweisung die überschritten die
maximalen Spenden die man machen kann
und die falschen Eintragungen in den
Büchern
verletzt das Gesetz in New York und
deswegen machte Donald Trump Donald
Trump falsch Erklärung zu seinen
Zahlungen an Michael Korne konnte nicht
sagen dass das Zahlen für Anwaltskosten
für Michael Korn waren
und das so darzustellen wäre ein
Verbrechen gewesen stattdessen sagte
Donald Trump dass er für fiktive
Anwaltskosten des Geldanlage 2017
bezahlt hätte um einen tatsächlichen
Verbrechen im Vorjahr zu vertuschen
um Michael Kohn sein Geld zurückzugeben
planten sie noch eine weitere falsche
Aussage
um den Plan zu komplettieren
wurden in dieser Zahlungen als Einkommen
von Michael Co und gegenüber den
Steuerbehörden in New York dargestellt
und bei den Punkten geht es um
Verbrechen im Staaten New York und
korrekte Geschäftsunterlagen sind
überall wichtig und sie sind noch
wichtiger in Manhattan das ist ja das
Finanzzentrum der Welt und deswegen
haben wir
im
bezirksstaatsanwaltsbüro von New York
eine Tradition
solchen Verbrechen nachzugehen und mein
Amt hat hunderte Fälle aufgenommen gegen
die falsche von
unternehmerischen Unterlagen das ist das
normale Geschäft meiner Behörde
hier in Manhattan haben wir solche
Anklagepunkte gemacht gegen die ich
Ihnen die Bank Geheimnis verlässt haben
oder die versucht haben sexuelle
Verbrechen zu vertuschen oder wir haben
einfache Punkte gegen diejenigen
vorgebracht die das Steuerrecht zuletzt
haben im Kern geht es bei diesem Fall um
Anklagepunkte wir in vielen
Betrugsfällen haben hier wurde gelogen
und zwar immer wieder um die eigenen
Interessen zu schützen und
Gesetze zu übertreten und für alle
müsste für Verantwortung übernehmen und
heute halten wir unsere Verantwortung
aufrecht dafür zu sorgen dass jeder von
den besetzt gleich ist egal wie viel
Geld er hat und wie viel macht er hat
das ist ein langanhaltendes
amerikanisches Prinzip und jetzt
stehe ich für Ihre Fragen zur Verfügung
wir haben eine genaue Ermittlung
durchgeführt wie wir das mal machen in
der bezirksstaatsanwaltschaft wir machen
das schon seit 24 Jahren und wir kennen
Stränge komplexe Ermittlungen und dieser
Fall war bereit nachdem wir eine genaue
Untersuchung durchgeführt haben und das
der Fall war eben reif für das Gericht
im wahren vor Gericht gebracht
sagen
die Anklageschrift enthält nichts was
nicht in den Gesetzen verlangt wird und
ich habe einige Gesetze angemerkt einige
Paragrafen zunächst mal das Wahlgesetz
von New York vom Stadt New York dort ist
er Verbrechen sich zu verabreden eine
Kandidatur durch umsetzliche Mittel zu
fördern
dazu gehört auch falsche Erklärungen
oder erkläre falsche Erklärung gegenüber
den Steuerbehörden und dann habe ich
mich auf das
Bundeswahlgesetz bezogen das auch
verletzt wurde
[Musik]
also die Beweismittel nach dem
gesetzliche Grundlage für die
Anklagepunkte die wir vorgebracht haben
jetzt nicht jeden einzelnen Punkt nennen
wir haben
einige Monate daran gearbeitet in der
Staatsanwaltschaft
bei den Ermittlungen ging es um die
Grundlage für die gesamtlagepunkt wir
haben über die Zeit immer mehr Hinweis
bekommen auch mit Zeugen gearbeitet wir
machen das ja schon seit 24 Jahren und
wir bringen keine Fälle vor Gericht
bevor wir nicht ganz klar und
gewissenhaft ermittelt haben
ihr Vorgänger hat diesen false kritisch
betrachtet und gesagt er würde den nicht
verbringen und
bundesstaatsanwälte angefahren nicht
vorgebracht sich vor Gericht was haben
Sie neue Beweismittel warum bringen Sie
den Fall jetzt vor Gericht wie ich
vorhin schon gesagt habe
hatten wir zusätzliche Weise die vor
meiner Zeit in der Staatsanwaltschaft
nicht verfügbar waren
und was die bundesbürden angeht
wir haben jetzt wir haben natürlich
einen großen Interesse an New York was
ich hier Tod wir sind das Geschäft die
geschäftshauptstadt der Welt und wir
bringen immer wieder solche betrugsziele
vor Gericht hier geht es um die
Integrität der Unternehmen hier und um
unsere geschäftliche Grundlage und wir
haben es im Fall vor Gericht gemacht
weil das für New York für den Staat New
York so wichtig ist
also ich werde jetzt nicht über das
hinausgehen was ich schon gesagt habe
also die Anklage lautet auf Fälschung
von Geschäftsunterlagen und wie schon
sagte
dazu gehört verbrecherisches Verhalten
das vertuscht wurde und eines der
Verbrechen Betracht das New Yorker
Waldgesetz
und sie haben das ja vorsicht es geht um
Textnachrichten E-Mails
telefonaufzeichnungen all das
wir hätten einem öffentlichen
Gerichtsverfahren in Downtown Manhattan
vorgebracht werden
ich freue mich dass Sie das ansprechen
denn es geht nicht um eine Zahlung
es geht um 34
falsche Angaben in Geschäftsunterlagen
wodurch kriminelles Verhalten vertuscht
wurde und deren Fragen zum Wahlgesetz in
New York da geht es mal eine
Verschwörung um eine Kandidatur durch
illegale Mittel zu fördern und wir sagen
dazu gehörte eben auch das Verhalten
was in der Tatsachen aufliste
untergestellt wurde zusätzliche
falsche Angaben in den ami-dokumenten
es geht also nicht nur um diese eine
Zahl von 130.000 die überwiesen wurde
vielen Dank
das war der Oberstaatsanwalt Alvin Break
wir haben ihn gehört er sagte jeder ist
gleich vor dem Gesetz und hat sich also
zu den 34 Anklagepunkten geäußert die
Anklage lautet Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen dazu gehöre auch
seit der eben gesagt verbrecherisches
Verhalten dabei wurde eben kriminelles
Verhalten vertuscht so heißt es es geht
um eine schweigegeldzahlung in Höhe von
130.000 Dollar ihr habt es gehört aber
auch noch weitere schweige Geldzahlungen
dabei wurden wohl Dokumente gefälscht um
ich zitiere jetzt mal vor und nach der
Wahl von 2016 schädliche Informationen
und rechtswidrige Aktivitäten vor den
amerikanischen Wählern zu verbergen
darüber können wir jetzt noch mal
sprechen mit unserem us-rechtsexperten
mit Kirk Junker der noch bei uns ist
Herr Junker war dafür sie jetzt
irgendwas überraschendes dabei
eigentlich nicht wenn wir
erstens
soll ich auch ein Lob geben an ihre
Dolmetscher also ich gebe völlig zu wie
schwierig es ist gleichzeitig technische
juristische Begriffe zu
übermorgen da geben wir Ihnen recht wir
sind dankbar dass bei ihnen auch hatten
jetzt gerade in diesem komplizierten
Fall genau ja und dann gehen wir zurück
zum was nicht durchgemacht war was die
Anwälte gesagt haben ich glaube wir
haben das nur auf englisch gehört die
die Trump Anwälte
das ist ja wichtig sie haben uns ähm und
ich habe meine wie wie gute Studierende
ich habe Notizen geschrieben
die was wir von den Trumps Anwälten
gehört haben ist wahrscheinlich ihre
erste Antrag unzureichende Beweise sie
haben gesagt es gibt keine Tatsache drin
ich habe diese 34 gelesen in der Pause
und es gibt doch Tatsachen drin warum
wollen sie das denn sagen weil das ist
quasi ihre schau was sie haben uns schon
dann ein Hinweis gegeben was die erste
Schritt von er verteidigen ist
zweitens und dann was wir von der Herr
Break jetzt gelernt haben
ist das wir wie ich vorher erwähnt habe
wirklich die ganze Dinge unter den
Schirm von von Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen bringen soll
trotz dass es etwas mit stormy dinosal
Kern mit google hat es hat wirklich mit
dieses zwei Frauen nichts direkt oder
persönlich zu tun sondern dass diese
zwei
Frauen waren bezahlt in eine
Verschwörung für den ganzen Plan oder
hat das Wort Plan benutzt um die alles
was negativ war irgendwie zu verbergen
und das ist den Kern dann von diese
Kriminalität das war sehr wichtig für
den Staatsanwalt zu hören zweite Denken
von Staatsanwalt zu hören was sehr
wichtig war wie oft erfahren die die
Bevölkerung von New York gesprochen hat
er Staatsanwalt für New York State es
kann Bundesstaatsanwalt und seiner
Aufgabe ist die Leute in New York zu
verteidigen ihre Interesse dann hat er
uns gesagt New York ist der ökonomische
Kapitel der Welt vielleicht ist es
vielleicht ist das nicht weiß ich nicht
aber in dem Sinn wir könnten die zwei
Dinge zusammenbringen das hat nichts mit
mit Tommy danielus zu tun sondern von
welcher eintragen im Geschäftsunterlagen
und New York hat besondere Interesse in
business weil New York ein
weltökonomischer Hauptstadt ist
es zeigt er hat dann wahrscheinlich
seine seine opening-statement wenn ein
Jury gibt eine Jury gibt er hat
wahrscheinlich dann schon sein Opel ins
Leben uns gegeben
das war das Opening Statement glauben
sie und jetzt aber was wir auch gehört
haben übereinstimmende Medienberichte
mehrere das eben eine persönliche
Anhörung für diesen Fall erst für den 4
Dezember geplant ist also dann würde es
erst losgehen warum verstreicht er denn
jetzt dann so viel Zeit
ähm wie gesagt also ich habe in in
unsere ungefähr unsere Stunde
nichts gesehen warum das so lange dauern
soll
es war wahrscheinlich schon gesprochen
und für alle die die Anwälte und der
Richter und
was geplant ist wie viele von dieser
Anträge gemacht werden wie lange es wird
dann dauern ein eine ein Jury zu nehmen
das kann ich nur vorstellen also das ist
nur eine Einschätzung kann ich nicht
sagen mit Sicherheit und dann ganz zum
Schluss auch dass meine lange Sendung
aber letzte Frage noch an Sie Herr
Junker jetzt mit all dem was sie gehört
haben also jetzt noch mal diese ganz
konkreten Anklagepunkte all das was der
Oberstaatsanwalt gesagt hat hat das
jetzt noch mal irgendwas an ihrer
Einschätzung verändert weil wie das
Ganze weitergehen könnte sie haben uns
ja schon viel erklärt aber war da noch
was für Sie drin was jetzt für sie noch
mal was verändert hat ich hoffe ihr habt
was erklärt mir nicht sicher
nein ich glaube was ich gehört habe aber
von von mindestens von den
Staatsanwaltschaft ist aus man spricht
von ähm man sagt das eigentlich wollte
ich wissen also Staatsanwaltschaft
Theorie warum haben sie das gebracht und
in der Zeit seit letzte Woche haben wir
von trump-seite hauptsächlich gehört nur
Hexenjagd Politik und so weiter und so
fort aber was wir heute Abend gehört
haben
von von Alvin Bruggen in
Staatsanwaltschaften New York sie müssen
Business business in New York
ökonomische Interesse verteidigen und
die Bevölkerung von in New York
Verteilen von Geldwäsche und solche
Leute die die diese
[Musik]
Geschäftsunterlagen wurde
das das ist ein bisschen trocken das ist
nichts dominanus aber das ist ihre
Theorie die sind in diesem Fall
und jeder ist gleich vor dem Gesetz das
wurde noch mal betont vor dem
Oberstaatsanwalt vielen Dank Herr Junker
für diese viele viele Zeit die sie uns
geschenkt haben und die spannenden
antworten wir werden das Ganze weiter
begleiten sie dann auch hoffentlich
wieder unser Gast und bis dahin erstmal
vielen Dank an sie
sehr gerne vielen Dank Frau jung danke
schön schönen Abend und natürlich
schönen Abend auch an euch dann kann
alle die dran geblieben sind so lange
mit uns gemeinsam angeschaut haben wir
bleiben natürlich klar an diesem Thema
für euch weiter dran berichten dann
jederzeit wieder live wenn es nötig ist
bis dahin erstmal gute Nacht und tschüss